اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
المتواصله لاحداث السودان شكرا للزميل
طالب كنعان اذا مشاهدينا اربع هدن انهارت
وساطات فشلت ونداءات دوليه
شتت او صداها دويه رصاص لم يهدا منذ سبعه
شتت صداها ذوي رصاص لم يهدا منذ سبعه ايام
المواجهه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
مستمره ولا افق لحل سلمي او حتى لحسم
عسكري وما خوف دوليه من كارثه انسانيه
تضرب السودان المتعثر في ازمات اقتصاديه
وسياسيه متتابعه منذ سنوات
[موسيقى]
الخراب والدمار واصوات الرصاص ما تركت
مجالا لفرحين يستحقه اهلنا في كل الربوع
بلادنا الحبيبه فاننا للجد حزينون لهذا
المال لكن يبقى الامل الدائم في اننا مع
شعبنا العظيم سنتجاوز هذه المحنه ونخرج
منها اكثر وحده وقوه وتماسك ويزداد هتافنا
قوه جيش واحد شعب واحد فاننا على ثقه في
تجاوز هذه المحنه بالدربه والحكمه والقوه
بما يحافظ على امن وحده البلاد وفيما
يمكننا من الانتقال الامن للحكم المدني
المواطنين الشرفاء انما اذ نترحم على كل
شهداء بلادي نتمنى الشفاء للجرحى وندعو
الله ان يعود علينا هذا العيد وبلادنا
تنعم بالامن والسلام
تحيه لكم جند بلادي وانتم تقدمون انفسكم
فداء لهذا الوطن العزيز عاش السودان حرا
مستقلا
اذا شهدت شوارع الخرطوم بحري انتشار
دوريات راجل للجيش السوداني بعد ان انسحبت
قوات الدعم السريع من مواقع في العاصمه
قال المتحدث باسم الجيش السوداني العميد
نبيل عبد الله بان الجيش قبل كل طلبات
الهدنه الا ان ما وصفه بالطرف الاخر هو من
خرقها
القوات المسلحه في الحقيقه ثلاثه
ووافقت عليها القوات المسلحه جميعا وكان
شرطنا الوثيف هو ان يلتزم
ما تنص عليه هذه الهدنه من اي من توقف اي
تحركات عسكريه وعدم استخدام السلاح وعدم
استخدام الرمايه القناصه من اسطح المباني
التي نشروها في محيط الخرطوم وفي وسط
الخرطوم ومريحيط بالقياده العامه وفي بعض
الاحياء السكنيه في وسط الخرطوم الخرطوم
ومناطق اخرى متفرقه نحن اعلنا فورا في
الثلاث مرات موافقتنا على هذه الهدنه
للجوارب الانسانيه ولكن الذي انه الاولى
لا لا ينتهي الطرف الثاني بهذه الهدنه
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا اللواء بدر الدين
حسن عبد الحكم الباحث في اكاديميه الامن
العليا للدراسات الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه لو بدر الدين مرحبا بك معي
في هذه التغطيه المتواصله على شاشه
العربيه يعني التصريحات
متضاربه المعلومات متضاربه الفيديوهات
ايضا حتى التي ينشرها الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع ربما من اماكن قريبه جدا في
السودان نسال هنا عن الانتشار العسكري
لكلا الطرفين كيف يمكن وصفه وشرحه
طيب بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم حقيقه خمس
ايام من العمليات التي قامت بها المسلحه
للدفاع عنها الدفاع عن
القياده العامه وبعض المرافق الاستراتيجيه
تحولت الرواتب المسلحه في تفكيكده الى الى
المرحله الثانيه كما اعلنت وهي مرحله
تنظيف وتنشيط
المدن مدينه الخرطبه حي الخرطوم
لان القوات المسلحه بعدها بعدها ان شك
احدث الضربات هائله في الدعم السريع عبوات
المسلحه القوات المسلحه عاصيه على
الانكسار
لتاريخ
ولذلك
الخمسه ايام الاخيره وهو تراجع ضوات
الدعوات الدعم السريعه المتمرده الى الى
الى الى الاحياء السكنيه للاحتمام الجويه
الى المرحله الثانيه وهي مرحله تمشيط
وبدات هذا العمل في مدينه الخرطوم بحري
اذا انتشرت
مواقع في الولايه بالمدينه تقتحم العمارات
العاليه التي نصبت فيها
الاسلحه القناصه وغيره وهنالك معلومات بان
عدد من القناصه غير سودانيين عليها
حالت من الدفع وتدمير عدد من السيارات بعد
ان بعد ان الدفع عليه الى مناطق الى شمال
شمال الخرطوم وانتقلت العمليات من اخنو
جنوب العالميه الازرق شمال الخرط البحري
وهي حقيقه انا اعتقد في نهايه التمرد الذي
قام به الدعم السري عام الخرطوم
لا لا شيء الان في القصر الجمهوري بعد ان
بعد ان احدث يعني الغواصه المسلحه قامت
بانزال جوي بانزال مظله وتمطر من تحرير
المطار المطار لم يكن محتلا يعني نتيجه
العمليات قامت بها رواه الدعم الشريعه
المتمرده انما كانت هي كانت يعني هنالك
توزيع من عمل 2019 عن ان يتولى الد
عم
تامين المرافق الاستراتيجيه والخدميه من
ضمن العصر الجمهوري وزاره الخارجيه
والمياه والكهرباء من ضمن وجزء من القياده
من القوات البريه لتفويل القوات الدعم
السريعه الى اليمن لانه البريه
على المطار لذلك
لضرب
ضربات البريه بعد ان بدا يتحدثون انه
محتلين جزء من القياده الان وسط الخرطوم
خالي من الدعم السريع انتقلت مواطن لاقصى
جنوب الخرطوم بعد ان دفعت بهم لكن لكن
السؤال السؤال لواء بدر اذا سمحت لي يعني
هل فرت هذه الفلول هل فرت هذه هؤلاء
المقاتلين من الدعم السريع من العاصمه
الخرطوم الى خارج الخرطوم ام احتمت في بعض
المنازل للمواطنين السودانيين في الخرطوم
قبل ذلك قبل ان تجيب علي اشاهد واياكم
مشاهدين ايضا سويا صور صباح اليوم من مقر
القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه السودانيه كما يظهر امامنا افراد
من الجيش
السوداني نستمع ثم نعود القياده
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
كل سنه والشعب السوداني بخير والجيش
السوداني بخير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعود مره اخرى الى اللواء بدر الدين اللي
هو بدر كنت قد سالتك قبل هذا الفيديو عن
مقاتلي قوات الدعم السريع هل غادروا
العاصمه الخرطوم بعد ان كانوا يعني
يتمركزون في القصر الجمهوري بالقرب ايضا
كذلك من المطار المدينه الرياضيه وكذلك
بعد ان قاموا بعض المراكز او نقاط التفتيش
ام انهم يعني كما تقول بعض الانباء
والمعلومات يعني يحتمون داخل بعض المنازل
للمواطنين السودانيين في الخرطوم ان كانت
لديك معلومه
كبيره جدا
[ضحك]
في عدد من الغمازات الان القوات المسلحه
عبر مواطن الخاصه
يحررون
منزل منزل عماره عماره حتى الشعب السوداني
جماهير الشعب السوداني
عندما يزود غماص الى اي عماره من عمارات
المحيط المطار فان المواطنين كانوا يتصلون
بالقياده العامه ويبلغوهم بذلك
في انتشار
المسلحه يعني استقبلته الشعب السوداني
استقبال حاشد لهم الحلوى وغطيوهم العصائر
وغيرها الغور
التي
يعرف اقصد بحري جزء منها ثم ضربه لانه اي
حركه من داخل المدينه للشوارع الريفيه
هنالك طائرات بدون طيار تغمص هذه
الاعراضات لذلك جزء منهم تم القضاء عليهم
جزء منه الجزء الثالث فره الى احياء اخرى
وحتستمر العمليات الان يعني استمرت لحد
كوبري كوبري
المس
لحه على علي العمارات التي تقع شرق المطار
التي يوجد بها عدد من الجماغ وهذه كان
المقصود بها يتم اقتحام يعني هنالك
يعني ربما تكون نقطه مهمه لواء بدر اين
تتركز هذه العمليات عمليات التمشيط ما
الذي نتج ايضا عنها انت قريب طبعا من
الامور العسكريه وربما تتابع عدق التفاصيل
فيها
التمشيط الان في بحري يعني تنشيط يعني ان
تقتعم القوات البريه والمدعومه بالمدرعات
احياء الاحياء الخرطومه الشرجيه
والبحر لانه لانه يضعف في هذه الاحياء
استعمال الغوات الجويه الا انها مختلفه
بالسكان
وم
ضاعه هذه الغوات
وانها تخسر وتنهى وتنهض وتقتل وتاخذ الحزب
هذه من النساء
الكهربائيه ونكشه الكهربائيه والاموال
لذلك كان هنالك خط واضح واحمر ان لا
تستعمل القوات الجويه داخل احياء مدينه
الخرطوم
هل هل هناك شهود عيان اكدوا هذه المعلومات
بان هناك عمليات نهب سرقه جرائم حقيقه هذه
المعلومات ايضا لواء بدر مع مرة عندي
فيديو في داخل هذا الموبايل ممكن ارسلها
لكم انهم يلعبون وياخذون الان
البنوك واخذوا كثير من الاموال انا عندي
فيديوهات ممكن ارسلها لكم وصورت من اعلى
المنازل من الاسر وتم الدفع
هنالك القوات المسلحه يتعامل معهم
المواطنين يرسلون اليه فيديوهات
والمعلومات
الجنيه الاولى من المعلومات بينما ارتكزت
هذه القوات
او عريستين او ثلاثه عربات كانوا يرسلون
هذه المعلومات الى القوات المسلحه من هذه
القوات المتمرده
ذائبه وغسلوا عدد من الدعم السريع
المتمرده كبير من جنوده السود
انيه ولا يعرفون من اين يخرجون وكثيرا ما
يقعوا صيبا سهلا لغواته الغوات الشعب
المسلحه
ساعود اليك مره اخرى ابقى معي لواء بدر
الدين حسن اذا مشاهدينا اظهر فيديو متداول
يظهر او يظهر عضو مجلس السياده الفريق اول
ياسر العطب وهو يتفقد القوات التي نشرها
الجيش اليوم بالخرطوم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كاميرا العربيه مشاهدينا هي اول وسيله
اعلاميه تتمكن من تصوير قاعده الدعم
السريع في منطقه جبل سركاب شمال ام درمان
وكانت قوات الجيش السوداني قد سيطرت على
القاعده قبل ايام
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
انتشر مقطع فيديو يظهر سيارات دفع الرباعي
مدمره تابعه لقوات الدعم السريع بعدما
قصفتها القوات الجويه السودانيه
[موسيقى]
قالت مجموعته الازمات الدوليه في بيان ان
الاشتباكات الحاليه في السودان قد تتطور
الى حرب اهليه في حال لم يتوقف القتال بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع كما
دعت المنظمه البلدان المجاوره للسودان وكل
من لديه علاقه وثيقه مع البرهان وحميتي
بان يتم التواصل معهما لايجاد حل مناسب
لوقف الاشتباكات بين القوتين
نبقى في الخرطوم وينضم الينا من هناك
الصحفي النور احمد النور سيد النور مرحبا
بك معي في هذه التغطيه كل عام وانت بخير
اريد السؤال اولا عما تفضل به ضيفنا قبل
قليل والكثير من الاحاديث ايضا وربما
الاخبار والانباء التي تتحدث عن عمليه نهب
عمليات سرقه جرائم ايضا ارتكبت في العاصمه
الخرطوم من قبل بعض افراد قوات الدعم
السريع هل تستطيع تاكيد هذه المعلومات او
نمت الى علمك
اليوم كان اطول ايام الحرب منذ بدايتها
استمرارا حيث ان العمليات التي بدات منذ
الثانيه صباح الفجر اليوم بالتوقيت المحلي
حتى الان مستمره قبل دقائق حيث اسكن في حي
المعموره اهتزت منطقه جنوب 500 متر
للمنطقه التي تسكن فيها تم غلق في منزل
لا اعرف ما في داخله ولكن اهتزت كل
المباني حتى المنزل الذي يقيم فيه الان
اهتزت اهتز المنزل والزجاج النوافذ
بالتالي هذه عمليه استمرت 14 ساعه ويبدو
انها مستمره مما يتحدث عن عمليه قصف جوي
قات سيد النور تتحدث عن عمليات قصف جوي
اي نعم عبر طائرات مسيره تم قصف يبدو انه
قص في دقيق لانه تم تدمير منزل بصوره
كامله ولم تتاثر المنازل التي حوله يعني
هناك هدف تم قصته في هذه المنطقه ايضا تج
تمع اشتباكات
في في الطريق المؤدي الى مدنهم خارج من
الخرطوم الى ولايه الجزيره المجاوره
ويبدو ان هناك عدد من القوات الدعم
السريعه التي كانت ستمركز في احياء الطائف
والرياض لقد خرجت بعد الضغط عليها صباح
فجر اليوم خرجت في الاتجاه الجنوب الشرقي
نحن ولايه الجزيره وهناك شهوتها يتحدثون
ان عمليات ومواجهات مستمره في منطقه
المنطقه الجديده الثوره لا تزال مستمره
منذ ساعات
[موسيقى]
كان السرقات هناك
عدد
واي
ضا الان ذكروا ان هناك
من قوات الدعم في المرتكزة في بعض المناطق
غلها نهب الهواتف والنقود التي توجد فيها
وايضا بعض السيارات
امس تم غوص في سياره في شارع الستين
ونقتل شخص بنت كانت بجوار والدها في تلك
السياره
وكثير من النقاط تتحدث عن حالات السلب
والنهب التي يتم في بعض المناطق
ويتحدث كثيرون
انهم النقاله واموالهم ومقولاتهم التي
توجد معهم
اريد السؤال كذلك عن الاوضاع الانسانيه
الاوضاع الانسانيه الاوضاع الصحيه ايضا
كيف يمكن تقييمها الان
غالبيه المستشفيات الكبيره التي كانت توجد
في وسط الخرطوم الان يظهر الوصول اليها
لوجود الاشتباكات وموجود مخاطر في طريق
المطار الذي يؤدي الى وسط الخرطوم حيث
توجد مستشفى الخرطوم ومستشفى اثنين من
مستشفيات الاطفال ومستشفى الامراض القلب
ومستشفى
الاسنان ومستشفى
الاورام
[موسيقى]
وصفيات كبيره مستشفيات خاصه
وغيرها وبالتالي تاثرت الاوضاع الانسانيه
بصوره كبيره حتى المستشفيات العامله يظهر
الوصول اليها هناك عدد كبير من المستشفيات
توقع انقطاع
الاطباء الصحيه
او المواطنين لا يستطيعون حتى الوصول
اليها وبالتالي اعتقد ان وزاره الصحه
ينبغي ان تست
تنشيط العمل وتفعيل المراكز الصحيه
المنتشره في وسط الاحياء عبر كوادر متطوعه
وعبر الهلال الاحمر والطليبه الاحمد يمكن
تشغيل هذه المراكز الصحيه لان المستشفيات
الوصول اليها صعب جدا وفيه مخاطر اذا حتى
اذا كانت عامله قبل قليل كنت اسال ضيفي
ايضا كذلك عن تضارب الفيديوهات بين
الطرفين حول السيطره على بعض المواقع ربما
الحساسه احيانا او المهمه قصر الجمهوريه
المطار القياده العامه وربما تابعت قبل
قليل الفيديو الذي نشره الجيش السوداني
وهو من امام القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه في العاصمه الخرطوم هذا التضارب
في الانباء ما الذي يعنيه التضارب ايضا
كذلك في المعلومات نريد حقيقه ما يجري على
الارض حول هذه المواقع المهمه والحساسه
المتوفره حتى الان ان
الان اليوم وصل خرطوم هو اقل الايام هدوءا
اكثرها هدوءا حيث لا توجد عمليات واسعه في
وسط الخرطوم حول الغطو حول القياده يبدو
ان الجيش استطاع ان يسيطر على القياده
ويسيطر على القطره الجمهوري ولكن يبدو
الاوضاع في مطار الخرطوم لا تظل غامضه حيث
توجد قوات من الدعم الصحيحه داخل المطار
وفي شرقه ايضا وفي محيطه الغربي الناطق
المنتشرون والاعل
العمليات العسكريه تجري في
شارع النقي
[موسيقى]
والمؤدي الى شارع مدني هذه المناطق ويوجد
ايضا حالات قصف متقطعه في
منطقه شرق النيل
تسمع انفجارات
ايضا فيهم درمان في
حي البستان وفي
حي النخيل في غرب مدينه ام درمان وهو
الطريق المؤدي الى غرب السودان والى
كردفان والى دارفور ويبدو ان هناك قوات
منتشره كانت من الدعم السريع في تلك
المنطقه وتعاملت معها القوات
ونشرتي ايضا فيديو حتى قوات الدعم السريع
يعني من شارع مدني بالخرطوم وقالت ايضا
انها سيطرت على هذا الشارع هل هذا حقيقي
على ارض
الميدان ام ان هناك ايضا تضارب كذلك في
هذه المعلومه
هذا الطريق القوات التي كانت في
بعض الهواتف التي ذكرت الخرطوم بحري
والموجوده في الخرطوم في الشرق الخرطوم
الثوره والان في القرب مجمع الصناعات
الدفاعيه في طريق مدني وبالتالي هذه
الاشتباكات لا تزال مستمره لذلك من الصعب
نقول انه هناك جهه سيطره ولكن العمليات
مستمر منذ ساعات في هذا الطريق اين تنتشر
قوات الدعم السريعه اليوم في العاصمه
الخرطوم اماكن تمرركزها من خلال معلومات
المتوفره لديك
[موسيقى]
هناك قوه كبيره كانت تعرض المنطقه ايضا
حول المدينه الرياضيه وفي هذه المنطقه
الجنوبيه ايضا في شرق
المطار انتشر في بعض المناطق هذا المناطق
البعيده من وسط المدينه بحري في الطقوم
مدينه الخرطوم بحري وفي وس
ط الاحياء انت
شار لديها موقع محدد لنهيجه
انفجار كبير
ربما قبل قليل سيد احمد
وتعود مره اخرى
انتشار في بعض المناطق اذا سمحت قبل قليل
كان هناك دوي انفجار ربما ضخم
امامنا في الصوره ايضا تبدو
الدخان ايضا في الصور المباشره التي
تابعناها قبل قليل هذه الصور من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم نحاول يعني التاكد من
الموقع يعني تحديدا اذا هو في محيط نعم
مقر القياده العامه بالعاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم اذا دوي انفجارات كبيره في محيط
مقر القياده العامه بالخرطوم كنا قد
تابعنا قبل قليل الجيش
السوداني نشر فيديو بالقرب او من داخل
طبعا مقر القياده العامه من امام يعني
البوابه بوابه القياده العامه
بالعاصمه السودانيه الخ القياده العمل
للقوات المسلحه طبعا كما ذكرنا ذوي
انفجارات كبيره وانفجار ضخم قبل قليل
تابعنا واياكم على الهوائي مباشره اعود
اليك سيدي النور عذرا فقط لمقاطعتك لكن
كنا نتابع هذه الصور
المباشره اريد ان اسال عن
الاهميه اهميه المناطق التي يجري الان
فيها او تجري فيها الان هذه الاشتباكات
كما ذكرت جنوب الخرطوم في شارع مدني ايضا
كذلك بالقرب من شارع ايضا او جنوب المطار
كذلك
اهميتها استراتيجيا في هذه المعركه
العسكريه بين الطرف
استراتيجيه ولكن انتشار الابواب الدعم
المنطقه لانه الجيش منذ ساعات تمام
المبادره وصارت الان الجيش
والعمل
بتقطيع اوصال هذه القوات ومنعها من
الانتشار في الخرطوم
والضغط عليها للاسعار
خارج التي سحبت من شرق الخرطوم نحو شارع
مدني هي بثوب الضغط بسبب القصف المتواصل
من الطائرات
الطائرات المسيره والمروحيات
ايضا في جنوب الخرطوم هذه القوات ايضا
انسحبت من وسط الخرطوم كانت هناك
مركز شارع المطار
اذا سمحت بسماع لدوي طبعا
دوي الرصاص سيد النور اذا سمحت يعني اذا
سمحت فقط عذرا للمقاطعه سيد النور لكن قبل
قليل ايضا سماع لدوي اطلاق
الرصاص ربما رشقات من الرصاص قبل قليل
يعني سمعنا هذا الصوت
لازلنا نستمع الى الصوت الطبيعي
اذا دوين انفجارات كبيره اطلاق للنار ايضا
في محيط مقر القياده العامه بالعاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم
اذا هذه صور من محيط القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني في الخرطوم هذه الصور الخاصه
بقناه العربيه ذوي انفجارات كبيره اذا
واطلاق للنار في محيط مقر القياده العامه
بالخرطوم الجيش السوداني كما ذكرنا كان قد
نشر فيديو من داخل القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه بالعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم تصاعد
لاعمده الدخان منذ الصباح اليوم
يعني ربما هذه الصوره متكرره منذ بدايه
هذه
الاشتباكات وهذه
الازمه بين القوتين في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم وعدت كذلك من الولايات السودانيه
ابقى معي
ساعود اليك سيد النور مره اخرى تداعيات
المعارك اذا المشاهدين في السودان لا تزال
تركي بظلالها على القطاع الصحي مئات
المرضى في المستشفيات دون تلقي اي علاج
يذكر لنفاذ المستلزمات الطبيه تماما
جثه في شوارع الخرطوم مئات المدنيين لقوا
حتفهم
جثه مكدسه منذ ايام لا يمكن جمعها ودفنها
على وقع الاشتباكات
القطاع الطبي كارثه انسانيه ضغط هائل على
سعته الاستيعابيه
وفق منسق البرامج الطبيه في السودان دخول
حوالي 400 شخص يوميا الى المستشفيات عشرات
الوفيات في مستشفيات الخرطوم لعدم تلقي
المصابين العلاج لا مستلزمات طبيه ولا
اكسجين
وفاه اكثر من 600 شخص والارقام مرشحه
للسياده
اكد المسؤول الاعلامي للهلال الاحمر
السوداني في تصريحات خاصه للعربيه ضروره
فتح مسارات امنه للكوادر الطبيه لتتمكن من
انقاذ المصابين
لم يتم الحصول على ممرات امنه لانه
الممرات الامنه دي مطلب كل المؤسسات
الوكالات الانسانيه لاخلاء المصابين
وتسهيل عمل الفرقه الطبيه للوصول الى
المستشفيات يلا نتمنى انه نحن في بمناسبه
العيد انه تحصله فعليه وتعلن مسارات امنه
لنقل واخلاء الجرحى والمصابين
قال عطيه عبد الله سكرتير نقابه الاطباء
في السودان للعربيه ان 11 طبيبا قتلوا
خلال المواجهات بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع بالاضافه الى تعرض عدد من
المستشفيات الى القصف ما تسبب بتوقف عمل
بعض المستشفيات
[موسيقى]
قالت منظمته صحه العالميه اليوم الجمعه ان
413 شخصا قتلوا واصيب ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه
واحد
وخمسون في السودان منذ دلاع الاشتباكات
يوم السبت الماضي وكانت منظمه الصحه قد
ابلغت امس الخميس عن مقتله 330 واصابه
قربت 3200 شخص جراء الاشتباكات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع بالسودان
[موسيقى]
ومعي هنا في الاستوديو مديره مكتب العربيه
في الخرطوم لينا مرحبا بك معي مره اخرى في
هذه التغطيه المباشره للعربيه استمعت ربما
لارقام منظمه الصحه العالميه هل من
تاكيدات لهذه الارقام اولا او معلومات او
تحديثات جديده اهلا نايف مره اخرى الانباء
كما تراها متضاربه والبيانات متضاربه فيما
يتعلق بالاحصائيات الرسميه لاعداد القتلى
سواء كان من الامم المتحده او من نقابه
الاطباء او من وزاره الصحه هذا يعني ان
الاليات مختلفه لكل جهه لقياس اعداد
القتلى والمصابين الواضح تماما انه لا
توجد اي اعداد دقيقه حتى الان او احصائيات
دقيقه لهذا الامر لانه لم تكشف اي جهه بعد
عن هذه الاليات المستخدمه ونسبه لاعتراف
كل هؤلاء الجهاد او كل تلك الجهات على ان
هناك جثث ما زالت في الشوارع ملقاه بان
المصابين لم يصلوا جميعهم المستشفيات كانت
كان هناك متطوعون يذهبون الى بعض المنازل
الى المصابين القريبين منه في اماكن السكن
فبالتالي هذه الاحصائيات ليست دقيقه
ولكنها قد تكون اقرب للحقيقه هناك
احصائيات قالها وزير الصحه انه نحو 600
قتيل وهناك فيديوهات انتشرت الى ان اغلب
القتلى الان هم من الجانب العسكري وفيهم
ايضا كثير طبعا من المدنيه عن 600 شخص
ربما تزيد هذه النسبه طبعا عن 600 شخص
يعني وفقا لبعض الاحصاءات او لبعض
المتابعين نتحدث عن الجانب المدني والجانب
العسكري بين الطرفين نعم نتحدث بين الجانب
المدني والعسكري ولكن الجانب العسكري
الجثث الموجوده في الشوارع هي الاكثر بحسب
الفيديوهات المنتشره
بالضبط انا اتذكر يعني في في في مرات
سابقه كنت قد تابعتي هذا الموضوع موضوع
الجثث في العاصمه الخرطوم وربما يبدو تسال
هنا لماذا تتكدس هذه
الجثث في الخرطوم وهل تشكل الجثث الموجوده
اليوم في الشوارع عبئا على المستشفيات او
على المشارح الموجوده في الخرطوم تشكل
نايف لانه هناك حادثه مشابهه حدثت قبل نحو
ربما ثلاثه اعوام حادثه فض اعتصام القياده
العامه كان هناك رفض بان تدفن تلك الجثث
ما لم يتم التعرف على هويه اصحابها ومعرفه
سبب القتل لانه لم تكن هناك اي جهات في
ذلك الوقت بامكانها ان تقوم بمعرفه اسباب
القتل او تحديد الهويات او استخدام حمض دي
ان ايه لتحديد الهويه تكدست هذه الجثث
بمرور السنوات فاصبحت هناك ثلاثه مشارح
رئيسيه في الخرطوم لكل مشرحه نحو الف جثه
الان هذه الجثث الملقاه على الشوارع كما
اشرت انت في سؤالك تشكل عبء اضافي لانه
حتى اللح لم تتحدث وزاره وزاره الصحه عن
اماكن جديده لاستقبال الجثانين هذا يشير
بصوره واضحه الى ان هذه الجثث المرقاه في
الشارع ربما تكون الان اضمن ان تكون ملقاه
في الشارع من ان تاتي وتتكدس مع جثث اخرى
فبذلك تختلط الجثث القديمه مع الجديد وقد
تتحلل الجثث الجديده هي اشياء كلها سيئه
ومحزنه وهي مناظر لا يستطيع الكثيرون
التعود عليها ربما كان يتحدث الطبيب شرعي
بانه هو فقط من يحتملون اصبحوا هذه
المناظر بتكرارها الكثير لكن هذا الوضع
الماساه الصعب يحتاج الى تضافر وتعاون بين
جهات مختلفه
للمعامله بصوره انسانيه في هذه الجسامين
الان طيب يعني هذه الصوره لالقاء هذه
الجثث في الشارع او بقائها ايضا في الشارع
اليوم الا يمكن ان تؤدي الى انتشار بعض
الاوبئه بعض الامراض ايضا زيادتها وفي
المقابل نحن نتحدث ايضا عن بعض المستشفيات
التي خرجت عن الخدمه المستشفيات اصلا غير
قادره على ان تستقبل المصابين والجرحى او
او القتلى فما بالك بالاوبئه او الامراض
صحيح اولا هو جانب انساني واخلاقي وديني
في المقام الاول ثم قد ياتي هذا الجانب
الصحي فعلا لتفشي يعني امراض بوجود هذه
الجثانين في الشوارع عدم معرفه اين ستذهب
ومن الذي بامكانه الان ان يحمل هذه
الجثامين والى اي مكان يعني ستؤخذ كل هذه
الان اسئله
مطروحه لا تجد اجابه حتى صباح هذا اليوم
كانت هناك مقاطع فيديو جديده تشير بصوره
واضحه الى استمرار بقاء هذه الجسمي في
الشوارع او تكدس تكدسها نعم هي متكدسه وما
يظهر ان هذا التكدس ليس في مناطق سكنيه
يظهر انه في مقر عسكريه تابعه للدعم
السريع باغلب الاحيان وقد تحدث قائد الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو في وقت سابق بان
لديه جنود كثر قتلوا في هذه الحرب بالتالي
الان نحن نتحدث عن اوضاع انسانيه جديده
تتطلب طريقه مختلفه للتعاون للتعامل
ولتحديدها ولكشفها ايضا للراي العام حتى
لا تكون مثل
الاوقات السابقه كان هناك اخفاء لكثير من
المعلومات وبالتالي اصبح الشارع السوداني
ولجان المقاومه لا يصدقون ما ياتي اليهم
لذلك من المقرر او من المفترض ان تكشف
الاليه للتعامل مع هذا الامر للراي العام
دعينا ننتقل الى الجانب الاساسي والمهم في
هذه المعركه وهو الجانب العسكري قبل قليل
دوين انفجارات كبيره اطلاق للرصاص الرشقات
متواصله مستمره من
الرصاص كذلك ايضا السؤال عن الانتشار
العسكري في الخرطوم كيف تبدو صورته
هناك الان تقدم للجيش في كثير من الشوارع
وهناك ايضا وجود لعربات الدعم السريع في
كثير من قرب الاحياء السكنيه وايضا في
شوارع العاصمه حتى اللحظه الاشتباكات تتم
الان
قرب القصر الجمهوري او في محيط القصر
الجمهوري وفي محيط القصر الجمهوري نحن
نعلم حتى اليوم ان الدعم السريع متواجد
داخل القصر والجيش يشتبك مع الدعم في محيط
القصر على العكس تماما اليوم المسيطر على
القصر الجمهوري هي قوات الدعم السريع لا
زالت تسيطر على القصر وخارج القصر هناك
محيط القصر محيط القصر يتواجد الجيش على
العكس في القياده العامه في القياده
العامه يتواجد الجيش وهو مسيطر على
القياده العامه منذ مساء اليوم الاول وبدء
اليوم الثاني سيطره تماما على القياده
العامه لكن الدعم السريع يتواجد في محيط
القياده العامه لذلك هذه الاشتباكات التي
تحدث هي في المحيط لانه متقاربين في
المكان يعني ان لا الصراع الان لا ياتي من
مناطق بعيده ياتي من مناطق قريبه
ذات الامر ايضا في شارع المطار الجيش
يسيطر على المطار الدعم السريع يحيط
بالمطار فهذه هي الان الاشتباكات على ذات
الامر وذات النسق شوارع الخرطوم هناك
شوارع تقدم فيها الجيش وهناك لقطات
للفيديو وكذلك شهود عيان اصبح الجيش منتشر
في شوارع اكثر من الدعم ولكن ايضا الدعم
السريع متمركز في كثير من المداخل للاحياء
وفي الشوارع العاصمه في الخرطوم وكذلك في
بحري بالتحديد هذا امر مؤكد بحسب
الفيديوهات المنتشره الحديث دائما عن
الخرطوم عن العاصمه لكن بالنسبه للخرطوم
بحري وتواجد قوات الدعم السريع وتمركزها
في تلك المنطقه نريد ان نعرف اهميه وجودها
في هذا المكان لماذا هي متواجده متمسكه
بموقعها في الخرطوم البحري
هي ليس لديها مواقع فقط في بحري لديها هي
مواقع مختلفه في ام درمان بحري والخرطوم
والدعم السريع معسكرات يمكن نحو خمسه او
سته معسكرات رئيسيه بحسب حديث للبرهاس
سابق انه تم القضاء على هذه المعسكرات او
عفوا بحسب حديث لي عضو مجلس السياده شمس
الدين كباشي انه تم قضاء قضاء على معسكرات
الدعم باستثناء اثنين لكن الان الدعم
السريع لا يتواجد في مقره هو الان يتواجد
في شوارع يتمركز في بعض المؤسسات في بعض
الدوائر الحكوميه في اماكن لديها رمزيه
مثل اللقطات التي ظهرت وبثها الدعم السريع
قبل قليل لتلفزيون السودان الدعم السريع
كان يتمركز داخل المقر الرئيسي للتلفزيون
الرسمي المقر الرئيسي نعم الجيش يسيطر على
المحتوى لان البث واجهزه البث ليست داخل
المقر الرئيسي للتلفزي
الصور التي بتت لوجود قوه الدعم السريع في
مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون كانت فقط في
السيطره على المبنى الذي يحتوي بعض
الشاشات ويمكن ايضا بعض المكاتب الاداريه
وغيرها وليست الاستديوهات تلفزيون السوداء
هو هناك في يعني الوضع ممكن معقد قليلا
للمشاهد العربي يعني هو التلفزيون مثل اي
تلفزيون عادي تتواجد فيه المكاتب
والاستديوهات وكل كل هذا لكن لا تتواجد
فيه اجهزه البث الرئيسيه
فبامكانهم البقاء مثلا في الاستوديو لكن
ليس بامكانهم بث اي محتوى من هذا الاستديو
لان الجهاز الرئيسي الذي يبث المحتوى هو
خارج هذه الاسوار ويسيطر عليه الجيش لذلك
هو التناقض ياتي بان الدعم السريع يسيطر
على مباني تلفزيون السودان والجيش يسيطر
على محتوى واجهزه بث هذا التلفزيون طيب
دعينا ننتقل لنشاهد سويا هذا الفيديو مع
المشاهدين ايضا هي صور الانسحاب قوات
الدعم السريع من الجنوب غرب العاصمه
السودانيه
الخرطوم نستمع للصوت الطبيعي ثم نعود
ايضا هذه
صور وفيديو لانسحاب مجموعه من قوات الدعم
السريع من محيط من محيط شركه جياد جنوب
غرب
الخرطوم اذا صور لانسحاب مجموعات من الدعم
السريع قوات الدعم السريع من محيط شركه
جياد جنوب غرب الخرطوم كانت قوات الدعم
السريع قد اعلنت ونشرت فيديو بانها تتواجد
في شارع مدنيته سيطر عليه في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم وهناك بعض الاشتباكات
طبعا
المتقطعه تشاهدين هذه الصور طبعا لنا ان
كان من تعليق
يبدو ايضا ان هناك نفاذ للاسلحه في بعض
ليس في كل في بعض المواقع التي يتمركز
فيها الدعم السريع
فتحدث بعض المرات اشتباكات هذه الاشتباكات
تظهر وهناك اصوات تكون في الهواء في بعض
الاحيان لا تتضرر منها مباني ولكن القصد
منها استهلاك الاسلحه الموجوده الدعم
السريع سيطر على هذا الشارع وبحسب شهود
عيان ومواطنين متواجدين في اماكن السكنيه
انهم قالوا الدعم السريع الان في هذه
الشوارع يبدو الان ان الجيش دخل قد تكون
لديه معلومات بنفاذ الاسلحه او نفاذ
المخزون بالتالي الان الدعم السريع ينسحب
من هذه الشوارع الى هذا الشارع يؤدي الى
كثير من الولايات لكن بامكانهم المرور عبر
ولايه الجزيره
وولايات اخرى وهذا الطريق لا يسيطر فيه
الدعم السريع على اي مواقع
الشوارع التي يعني تسيطر عليها قوات الدعم
السريع وكانت موجوده فيها وتم ابلاغ ربما
الجيش السوداني بانها تتواجد في هذه
الشوارع المهمه والرئيسيه كما ذكرتي نعم
انا لس
ت لكن لكن هناك حاله اقرب للكروه الفرد في
شارع المطار يتواجد الدعم السريع بعد قليل
يكون هناك فيديو لوجود الجيش نفس الامر في
ام درمان ونفس الامر في بحري المواقع
المستمره حتى اللحظه لم يحدث فيها كر وفر
هي المواقع في تلفزيون السودان في القصر
ومحيط القياده حتى اللحظه ما زال كل طرف
يتواجد في هذا المقر يعني اي طرف يتواجد
في مقر والاخر يتواجد في محيطه لم تحدث
حاله من الفوزه والانتصار ولكن هناك تقدم
بصوره واضحه يحدث في الشوارع في مناطق
بحري الخرطوم وام درمان
وهناك حالات كروه فرق هناك انسحاب ومحاوله
للدخول للاحياء هناك محاولات نايف ايضا
اخرى بان يتملص الذين يرتدون مثلا زي بان
يرتدوا زي مدني ان كانت نفذت اسلحتهم
وغذائهم حتى لا يتم استهدافهم طيب
ايضا كذلك ليوني ربما اليوم نحن طبعا في
اول ايام عيد الفطر المبارك
والسودان تعيش ربما عيد مختلف هذا العام
كيف استقبله السودانيين كيف السودانيون
كيف يعني عبروا عن هذه الحاله التي
يعيشونها هل يصطفون الى فريق عن طريق ما
هي حاله المواطن السوداني فيما يحدث اليوم
كان هناك حاله اقرب للتفاؤل بهذا اليوم
طبعا نحن نعلم ان الشعب السوداني كله حزين
ويعيش ماساه وهو امر معلوم بالضروره لا
يحتاج حتى لقول ولكن كان هناك تفاؤل بان
تنتهي هذه النزاعات لانه تعود كثيرا على
هذه الاجواء اجواء النزاعات واجواء التوتر
لكن اجواء الحروب في هذه العاصمه هو امر
جديد فهذا هو الامر الجديد على الشارع
والشعب السوداني صحيح ان هناك ولايات مثل
دارفور وغيرها كانت تعيش هذه الانواع من
الحروب لكن الان في الخرطوم هناك حزن هذا
الحزن مصحوب بقليل من التفاؤل بان ينتهي
هذا الامر يعني بصوره قريبه وبان ينتهي
هذا النزاع الذي يسبب دائما في السودان
توترات تسهم بان لا يتقدم السودان يعني لا
يوجد احد في السلطه يهتم بالخدمات بحاله
المواطنين بالتعليم بالصحه بغيرها دائما
ما هذا السياسي او تحديدا هو عسكري عسكري
عسكري نعم عسكري عسكري يكون موجود ويشغل
من هم في السلطه عن واجباتهم تجاه
المواطنين لذلك ان انتهى هذه انتهت هذه
الحرب ستكون هناك مراحل طويله لاعاده بناء
السودان لمرحله ما قبل الحرب ثم بعد ذلك
الذهاب قليلا الى الامام اشكرك جزيل الشكر
على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل تواجد معي
هنا في الاستوديو مديره مكتب العربيه في
الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لك
اكد دبلوماسيون اوروبي للعربيه انه يتم
العمل مع الهيئات الدوليه ودول الخليج من
اجل وقف اطلاق النار وتثبيت الهدنه في
السودان واضاف الدبلوماسيه الاوروبي ان
السودان دوله محوريه في افريقيا وان
تاثيرات النزاع قد تطاول المنطقه من غرب
افريقيا الى القرن الافريقي
من مدينه مروي ينضم الينا مراسل عربية
نزار بقداوي نزار كل عام وانت بخير اهلا
بك معي في هذه التغطيه الاوضاع في مروي
يبدو انها تتجه الى الاستقرار وسيطره
الجيش ايضا هناك الحاله العامه في مروي
كيف يمكن وصفها نزار
الحاله الذي
دعوات الطيبات
التي تشرب مروي حاليا حاله
التي جاءت بعد امس خرجت من هذه المنطقه من
المطار من القاعده
القوات المسلحه الان تسيطر بالياتها
باعتادها بجنودها بضباتها الفرقه التاسعه
عشر مشاه التي
تتبع لها القوات وهي تتبع للقوات المسلحه
بطبيعه الحال تتمركز في هذه المنطقه في
شمال السودان في حدود مسؤولياتها العسكريه
والامنيه
الامور في هذا اليوم بعد سبعه ايام من
العمليات والاشتباكات المسلحه
ثلاث ايام الى الخلف كانت مشروبه بالتوتر
والحذر والترقد لكن خلال اليومين الماضيين
يمكن ان نقول بان ملوي استعاد
ت اسيتها تدريجيا التقط المواطنون انفاتهم
بعد حاله التوتر التي لازمت المشهد خلال
اسبوع من الزمان
اذا سمحت
نحن نستمع
واياك الى ربما
ذوي اطلاق الرصاص ايضا رشقات من الرصاص
حول محيط القائد العمل الجيش السوداني في
الخرطوم نستمع للصوت الطبيعي
اذا مشاهدينا كما تابعنا واياكم ذوي
انفجارات
كبيره وسماع لرشقات
الرصاص في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم في
محيط القياده العامه للجيش السوداني
استمعنا واياكم اليها قبل قليل
وهذا دوي انفجار كبير ايضا اخر
اذا هذه هي الصوره من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطومه هي صوره متكرره يعني حقيقه خلال
هذا الاسبوع منذ بدايه هذه الاشتباكات صور
واصوات اطلاق الرصاص بهذا الشكل انفجارات
ايضا حتى كبيره
في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم بالقرب من
المحيط القياده العامه للجيش بالقرى عليها
الجيش كما نشر فيديو قبل قليل ايضا
من امام القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
طيب اذا الرصاص لا يتوقف
والدوي هذه الانفجارات ايضا كذلك لا يتوقف
من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم من محيط
القياده العامه للجيش في الخرطومسه نظل
نستمع الى الصوت الطبيعي من
الخرطوم ايضا لكن
اعود مره اخرى الى
اللواء بدر الدين حسن لواء بدر مرحبا بك
معي مره اخرى يعني لازلنا نستمع الى هذه
الاصوات عفوا الى هذه الاشتباكات الجيش
يعني كان قد اعلن بانهم سيطر على القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه بشكل كامل فاين
تدور هذه الاشتباكات القريبه من القياده
العامه للجيش
السوداني وكذلك اين تتركز بشكل اساسي
على هذا السؤال في بعض الاشياء التي يعني
يجب ان اوضحها تحدثت بانه هنالك في اللجنه
العاميه قد وزعت التامين العاصمه على
ثلاثه اجزاء والجيش الجيش يحمل القياده
العامه
والمرافق العسكريه
يحمل المرافق الاستراتيجيه والخدميه
والشرطه تحمي مظاهرات الشرطه والاسواق
لذلك الدعم السريع في العصر الجمهوري كان
وجودهم طبيعيا كان هنالك حوالي 50 عربيه
موجوده
في العصر الجمهوري الان الغفر الجمهوري
خالي من قوات الدعم السريع تم انزال جوي
انزال مظلات حتى انه احد الضباط المظلات
الفشل ولكن تم القضاء على الغوه
وغضب بعض الدعم السريعه الموجودين
وزاره الداخليه
وهربوا الى الى جنوب الخرطوم
المياه
اليها المحطات الكبيره
وعدد الكهرباء الى المنازل هذا النظام
واما ما يحدث من من تراشق في اسلحه صغيره
كلاشات وغيرها موجوده ربما تحدث يكون
لاحدا الدعم السريع موجود في احد في احد
المنازل الغريبه من القياده الع
امه لا حول القوات
القياده العامه من ناحيه الجنوب من
الناحيه الله الجنوب الغربيه ومن ناحيه من
ناحيه الجنوبيه وفي الناحيه الشرقيه لا
يوجد
جنوبيه الجنوبيه الجنوبيه الجنوبيه
الغربيه
نصب بعض القماصات لكن بدايه المرحله
الثانيه الان تحركت القوات المسلحه مسنوده
بالدبابات والطائرات الاخرى
الى
شعاق
شمال ولذلك يتحدثون ان ان واصل دعم السريع
تحتل شارع
هناك فرق بين هل
تحتل نشرت فيديو وقالت انها سيطره يعني
ابقى معي السيد بدر
نتابع هذه الصور
كما ذكرنا من محيط القيد العملي الجيش في
الخرطوم يعني دوي انفجارات كبيره واطلاق
رصاص وبعد ذلك تصاعد الان لاعمده الدخان
يبدو من محيط القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه يبدو بان هناك اشتباكات عنيفه كما
يظهر في الصور من خلال هذا الدخان
المتصاعد وربما استهداف لبعض المواقع احدى
طرفي الاشتباك في محيط العاصمه او في محيط
القياده العامه للجيش السوداني في الخرطوم
المقر الذي اعلنت
او الذي اعلن الجيش السوداني انه قد سيطر
علي نشر فيديو من امام القياده العامه
بوابه القياده العامه القوات المسلحه
لازلنا نسمع باستمرار منذ يعني
دقائق
اطلاق رصاص كثيف يبدو انها
مواجهات ربما في محيط القياده العامه
الجيش وقبله ايضا ذوي انفجارات كبيره في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم من خلال هذه
الصوره والكاميرا الخاصه لقناه العربيه
والتي تنقل الاحداث في العاصمه السودانيه
وفي عموم السودان اولا باول منذ بدايه هذه
الاشتباكات وهذا الاحتراب السوداني
السوداني منذ سبعه ايام
واستمعنا للدوي الانفجارات الكبيره اطلاق
الرصاص ايضا
الفيديوهات التي نشرها الطرفاء هذه
الحرب الجيش السوداني نشر فيديو من داخل
قياده القياده العملي الجيش في الخرطوم
القوات الدعم السريعه نشرت
فيديو من شارع مدني بان تسيطر علينا
[موسيقى]
اذا كما ذكرنا مشاهدينا هذه الصور مباشره
ننقلها لكم من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
من امام
محيط القياده العمل للقوات المسلحه والتي
تشهد دوي فيجارات كبيره واطلاق للرصاص
المتواصل قبل قليل كنا قد تبعنا واياكم
فيديو الانسحاب مجموعه من الدعم السريع من
محيط شركه جياد جنوب غرب الخرطوم
مصادر العربيه كشفت بان الجيش استهدف عبر
قصف كثيف مراكز تجمع لقوات الدعم السريع
هذه الساعه من التغطيه انتهت شكرا لكم
لكرامي ولطف المتابعه التغطيه على العربيه
مستمر ولكن مع الزميل طالب كنعان اليك
طالب تفضل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات